Der Supervulkan unter dem amerikanischen Yellowstone-Nationalpark
ist gigantisch.
Seine Magmakammer ist 40 Kilometer breit und
60 Kilometer lang - in ihr brodeln 15.000
Kubikkilometer Magma.
Eine riesige Gefahr!
Fest steht: Falls der Vulkan ausbricht, hätte
dies fatale Folgen für die Menschen auf der
gesamten Erde.
Einige Medien berichten jetzt über Alarmzeichen,
die auf einen zeitnahen Ausbruch des Vulkans
hindeuten könnten.
Willkommen bei Clixom Science & Fiction Hier
gibt es täglich faszinierende Science-Videos,
abonniert den Kanal, nur dann verpasst ihr
nichts.
Ein Horrorszenario - vor allem für die US-Staaten
Montana, Idaho und Wyoming und den gesamten
nordamerikanischen Kontinent: Der Ausbruch
des Yellowstones-Vulkans würde Glutlawinen
aus Lava und Asche mit einer Temperatur von
800 Grad Celsius niedergehen lassen.
Infrastruktur und Landwirtschaft hätten keine
Chance mehr.
Die Sonne käme nicht mehr zur Erde durch
- Wolken aus Schwefelgas würden dies verhindern.
Das globale Klima kühlt ab und die Ernten
in zahlreichen Regionen weltweit fallen aus.
74 Tage lang würden uns die weltweiten Nahrung-Vorräte
überleben lassen, danach würde wohl ein
Großteil der Menschen verhungern.
Fachleute sind sich schon lange sicher, dass
das komplette Leben auf der Erde durch einen
Ausbruch des Supervulkans bedroht wäre.
Deutlich macht das auch einmal das alarmierende
Statement de NASA-Mitarbeiters Brian Wilcox.
Demnach sei „die Forschung zu Supervulkanen
weitaus wichtiger ist, um die Menschheit vor
Gefahren zu schützen, als die Entwicklung
von Systemen, die Kometen und Asteroiden von
der Erde fernhalten“.
Und so haben Forschungsteams weltweit den
Supervulkan im Yellowstone-Nationalpark ganz
genau im Blick, um auch ja jede kleine Veränderung
registrieren zu können.
Im vergangenen Jahr beispielsweise erschien
eine spannende Studie, die unglaubliche Erkenntnisse
zum Supervulkan aufgespürt hatte.
Denn neue Messungen eines US-Forschungsteams
hatten gezeigt, dass ein Schlauch geschmolzenes
Gestein bis an die Grenze zum Erdkern reichen.
Und das sind unfassbare 2900 Kilometer!
Bislang waren Fachleute von einer Magmaquelle
in einer Tiefe von 440 Kilometern ausgegangen.
Doch die Bilder, die mit Hilfe von Erdbebenwellen
gewonnen werden konnten, legen nahe, dass
heißes Gestein von der Erdkern-Grenze unter
Mexiko schräg nach oben quillt.
Und zwar in einer 350 Kilometer breiten Zone
- bis in den Nordosten der USA.
Der obere Teil der Gesteinssäule wärmt darüber
liegendes Gestein.
Durch die Spalten gelangt das Magma, das wiederum
den Feld knackt.
Dennoch geht der Geologische Dienst der USA
“United States Geological Survey” (USGS)
beispielsweise nicht davon aus, dass eine
größere Eruption in der nächsten Zeit zu
befürchten sei.
Denn dafür müsse sich der Untergrund in
der Region stark verändern: Ein Drittel der
Magmakammer müsse geschmolzen sein, damit
sich der Brei wie Flüssigkeit verhält.
Messungen aber zeigen, dass derzeit weniger
als ein Zehntel des Gesteins flüssig ist.
Demnach sei das Magma in einzelnen Blasen
in Felssporen eingeschlossen.
Die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass eine große Eruption
des Supervulkans stattfindet, liegt dem USGS
zufolge im Jahr bei 1 zu 700.000.
Im Vorfeld würde es dann aber auch entsprechende
Anzeichen geben.
Der vermehrte Austritt von Gas beispielsweise
oder eine gehäufte Anzahl an Beben als ohnehin
im Yellowstone könnten als Alarmzeichen interpretiert
werden.
Letztendlich würde sich dann wohl auch der
Boden durch den Magma-Aufstrom wölben.
Einige Experten und Expertinne sehen sowieso
nicht den Supervulkan selbst als größte
Bedrohung, sondern die Erdbeben in dieser
Region.
Dazu der Geograph Michael Poland in einem
Interview (mit USA Today): “Es ist viel
weniger der Vulkan als vielmehr die Erdbeben,
die Schaden anrichten können — und werden.
(...) Das ist eine unterschätzte Gefahr im
Yellowstone Gebiet.
Es kann und wird in Zukunft Erdbeben der Stärke
7 geben.”
Pro Jahr werden in der Yellowstone-Region
durchschnittlich 1500 bis 2000 Erdbeben registriert.
Der Großteil davon ist allerdings zu klein,
um vom Menschen wahrgenommen zu werden.
Dies übernimmt ein großes Netzwerk von etwa
50 Seismometern.
Damit ist gehört diese Region zu den seismographisch
am besten bewachten der ganzen Welt.
Einige Newsportale und Zeitungen berichten
derzeit immer wieder darüber, dass die thermischen
und seismischen Aktivitäten rund um den Supervulkan
zugenommen hätten.
Im Herbst 2018 zeigten sich beispielsweise
einige Geysire im Yellowstone Park so aktiv
wie nie.
In rund zehn Meter Höhe spie beispielsweise
eine der heißesten Geysire der Gegend Gase,
vulkanisches Gestein und kochend heißes Wasser.
Zudem bilden sich Medienberichten zufolge
derzeit weitere Geysire.
Fachleute wie die vom Yellowstone-Vulkan-Observatorium
aber halten diese Ereignisse für nicht ungewöhnlich.
Demnach haben stehen diese Vorkommnisse “nicht
in direktem Zusammenhang mit der Bewegung
von Magma in mehreren Kilometern Tiefe.
Es gibt keine Anzeichen für eine bevorstehende
vulkanische Aktivität”.
Was passiert also als nächstes: Ein gewaltiges
Erdbeben oder der Ausbruch des Supervulkans?!
Auch, wenn Experten beide Bedrohungen gut
überwachen, ist diese Frage nicht zu beantworten.
Statistisch gesehen ist der schlummernde Vulkan
jedenfalls überfällig.
Die drei bisherigen Ausbrüche passierten
vor 2,1 Millionen Jahren, vor 1,2 Millionen
Jahren und vor 640.000 Jahren.
Doch selbst, wenn ernstzunehmende Alarmzeichen
beobachtet werden würden, wäre nicht klar,
welche Maßnahmen uns retten könnten.
Die “Geological Society of London” beispielsweise
hat in einem Gutachten über Supervulkane
festgestellt, dass keinerlei Notfallpläne
für solch eine Katastrophe existieren.
Und so tüftelt die US-Weltraumbehörde NASA
an einem kuriosen Plan, um den Supervulkan
zu entschärfen bzw. einen Ausbruch sogar
zu verhindern.
Ein Geothermiekraftwerk in der Nähe des Vulkans
könnte die Lösung sein!
Demnach müsste der Vulkan zunächst angebohrt
werden.
So könnte ihm das Kraftwerk langsam, aber
stetig, Wärme entziehen und die Magmakammer
langfristig abkühlen.
Die geschätzten Kosten des Projekts: 3,5
Milliarden Dollar.
Doch dadurch würde nicht nur die Gefahr eines
Ausbruchs eingedämmt.
Bei diesem Plan ließe sich sogar Strom gewinnen.
Zehn Kilometer beispielsweise müsste gebohrt
werden, um an 350 Grad heißes Wasser zu gelangen.
So ließe sich dann Strom für etwa zehn Cent/Kilowattstunde
herstellen.
FALLS das Projekt erfolgreich wäre, könnte
die Region um den Vulkan wohl für mehrere
hundert Jahre mit Strom versorgt werden.
Aber klar ist auch: Die Idee der NASA birgt
große Risiken Denn solch eine Bohrung könnte
tatsächlich die Katastrophe auslösen, die
es eigentlich zu verhindern gilt.
Die Magmakammer könnte instabil werden, wenn
Unternehmen in die tieferen und heißeren
Schichten bohren.
Die Folge: Der Ausbruch des Supervulkans!
Schon hier in Europa haben die Bohrungen für
Geothermie-Kraftwerke zu Erdbeben geführt.
Upsi.
Die drohende Katastrophe eines Teilchensturms.
Das ist im Moment jedenfalls eine größere
Gefahr.
Hier draufklicken, anschaun und Doktor Whatson
abonnieren.
Bis dann bleibt dran!